nous rejoindre il y a des problèmes de
transport qui font qu'ils ont dû
vérifier donc ils ont dû modifier leur
leur trajet et notre président également
Mathieu d'Arnaud n'a pas pu joindre à
nous
à cause également de ces problèmes de de
transport donc c'est moi René Paul
Savary sénateur de la Marne en tant que
vice-président qui avait organisé cette
entrevue
je vais faire quelques propos
préliminaires et vous passerez la parole
bien entendu ensuite donc nous sommes
heureux de vous accueillir monsieur
Viard
à distance mais en présence quand même
en présentiel la Journée Mondiale du
Tourisme se tient chaque année le 27
septembre
elle constitue depuis la première
édition l'ancien 1980 sous les gîtes des
Nations Unies l'occasion de faire le
bilan de l'année écoulée et de réfléchir
à la suite mais la journée d'avant-hier
n'était pas comme les autres parce que
si un domaine qui s'est trouvé
complètement bouleversé par la pandémie
c'est bien celui du tourisme d'ailleurs
comme quand lorsque nous nous sommes
réunis en début de l'été pour réfléchir
au prochain sujet dont pourrait se
saisir notre délégation la question de
l'avenir du tourisme avait immédiatement
suscité l'enthousiasme et c'est Cécile
ku Kermen qui était à l'origine de cette
proposition je le remercie
en un peu plus d'admi siècle le tourisme
cet enfant des 30 glorieuses à façonner
notre société notre économie notre
rapport au monde autant au voyage aux
loisirs à la consommation et à la
planète le nombre de touristes
internationaux est passé de 60 millions
à la fin des années 1960 à 1,5 milliards
en 2019 et la France accueille davantage
de touristes étrangers qu'elles ne
comptent d'habitants et puis du jour au
lendemain tout s'est arrêté les avions
les hôtels les restaurants les
spectacles et d'ailleurs la pollution
également
maintenant les questions qui se posent
si l'on en croit les chiffres publiés
cet été par l'Organisation mondiale du
tourisme la reprise est bien là et elle
est forte et l'Europe par exemple a déjà
retrouvé 80% de ces nouveaux de ces
niveaux d'avant crise mais par le ton
vraiment de la même chose le tourisme du
monde d'après est-il et surtout doit-il
peut-il être celui du monde d'avant une
chose est sûre nous sommes dans un
moment charnière une sorte d'année zéro
du tourisme un moment plein
d'incertitude mais déjà riche
d'enseignement un moment où s'ouvre de
nouvelles opportunités un moment où il
va falloir faire des choix l'an 0 du
tourisme c'est précisément le titre de
l'ouvrage que vient de cossigner avec
vous David Medioni le sociologue donc
Jean Viard directeur de recherche de ces
VIP hop que vous êtes le centre de
recherche politique des sciences pour
que nous avons le plaisir d'entendre ce
matin vous êtes monsieur VI spécialiste
du tourisme des temps de loisirs de la
mobilité ou encore de l'aménagement du
territoire mais aussi sur la méthode un
promoteur de longue date de la démarche
prospective
c'est d'ailleurs pour cela que le thème
de l'audition n'est pas le futur
dutrisme parce que nous nous doutons pas
qu'il y en ait un mais plutôt le
tourisme du futur
c'est à dire lequel tourisme en essayant
d'apporter des réponses à la fois
concrètes et de long terme vous êtes
aussi le cofondateur d'une maison
d'édition installée en Provence les
Éditions de l'Aube ce qui explique la
visioconférence de ce matin la
visioconférence voilà un autre exemple
de changement précipité par la crise
sanitaire qui n'est pas sans donner
quelques idées à ceux qui cherchent une
réponse à la sur fréquentation de
certains lieux touristiques faudra-t-il
demain passer par le métaver pour
visiter la tour de Pise la Tour Eiffel
sans faire la queue le Japon sans
prendre l'avion Versailles costume
d'époque et Pompéi en éruption immersion
voilà peut-être j'étais un peu loin mais
je vous laisse sans plus attendre la
parole et vous remercie bien entendu
pour votre disponibilité après votre
discours à nos propos introductifs en
tout cas nous nous permettrons de vous
poser des questions merci Monsieur Jean
Viard vous avez la parole
merci Monsieur le vice-président bon
parfait écoutez moi le tourisme ça fait
j'allais dire 50 ans que j'observe donc
je ne sers à certaines distances dans
l'observation
moi je dirais d'abord une chose nos
sociétés sont bousculées par la pandémie
une façon extraordinaire et ça ne fait
commencer
il y a des millions de gens qui
déménagent il y a des millions de gens
qui utilisent leur résidence secondaire
à mi-temps qui viennent en ville qu'à
mi-temps voyez je travaille sur la
défense en ce moment on a 30%
disponibilités dans les bureaux donc si
vous laissez pour dire qu'il est en
train de se passer quelque chose dans le
rapport à l'espace le fait d'habiter en
ville de pas habiter en ville etc ça
c'est la première chose je vous rappelle
que 70% des Français habitent dans des
maisons individuelles dont la plupart en
jardin et il y a effectivement puisqu'il
y a en France il y a 16 millions de
maisons individuelles pour 12 millions
d'appartements et les 12 millions
d'appartements il y en a à peu près la
moitié qui sont des familles
propriétaires de résidence secondaire
des familles pas forcément ça peut être
ses parents ou c'est ou ses enfants donc
en gros ça nous donne une France où vous
avez en gros 70% des gens qui ont un
jardin dans la ville il y a je vous
rappelle qu'à Paris 50% des logements
sont occupés par des personnes seules
donc le modèle de la ville de demain
c'est effectivement des personnes seules
des étudiants pour beaucoup mais pas
seulement et puis des touristes et les
deux groupes sociaux principaux d'une
métropole moderne et puis il y a les
gens qui viennent dans cette ville
prenez Paris 700 000 salariés habitent
la ville un million entre les matins et
2 millions d'autres personnes dans la
ville tous les jours pour voir tous ces
mouvements là et ces mouvements sont en
train de se déplacer parce que le nombre
de francs le télétravail c'est entre 30
et 40 % des emplois en ce moment c'est
trop un peu moins mais on pourrait aller
plus haut ça veut dire des gens qui
peuvent se déplacer dans l'espace parce
qu'ils vont venir en ville que une ou
deux fois par semaine on est en train de
construire des logements pour ces
gens-là où ils auront deux nuitées par
semaine toujours les mêmes au même
endroit avec leurs affaires etc et puis
on change trois fois dans la semaine et
on enlève le linge on enlève le linge on
remet etc vous voyez il y a toutes ces
évolutions pour dire que c'est pas
directement le tourisme c'est la toile
de fond du mouvement de l'espace c'est
important parce que les gens que une
maison avec jardin voyage moins que je
dis n'en ont pas par exemple vous voyez
tout ça va avoir une influence donc ça
c'est la la première remarque et donc on
est au début de ce mouvement en gros les
métropoles sont en train de s'étaler
dans l'espace dans la France des
résidences secondaires on pourrait le
dire comme ça il y avait déjà les métrop
c'était étalé dans l'espace j'allais
dire dans la France des gilets jaunes
pour aller vite c'est-à-dire le
périurbain des lotissements et les
petites villes en perdition si on peut
dire comme ça les gens vont travailler
dans la grande ville parce qu'il y a pas
d'emploi c'est un peu ça le modèle des
choses essentiellement le monde de la
justice la santé les petits boulots du
service ce qu'on travaillait pendant la
pandémie là on fait une autre France
c'est effectivement la France
patrimoniale des résidences secondaires
qui s'occupe d'habitants qui restent à
la ville et qui continuent à vivre avec
des salaires de la vie problème de
concurrence territoriale qu'on va très
bien en ce moment ça c'est la première
chose deuxième chose je pense que on
dira dans l'histoire que la civilisation
des loisirs a gagné sur la civilisation
du travail avec la pandémie vous savez
la grande peste de 1300 et quelques
c'est l'invention du salariat avant il y
avait pas de salariat avant il y avait
des cercles et puis il y en a la moitié
qui sont morts de la peste on a dû se
mettre à payer les salariés donc les
pandémies ça bouleverse en fait les
équilibres socioculturels en France je
vous rappelle que votre espérance de vie
de 700000 heures et que la durée légale
de travail pour avoir droit à la
retraite afin que le cas aujourd'hui
c'est 68000 heures ça veut dire que
votre temps de travail légal est
inférieur à peu près à 10% de votre
existence si vous laissez ça l'élément
structurant des sociétés modernes ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que la vie
s'est allongée de 20 ans depuis la
guerre et que plus la vie est longue
plus on la vie par séquence courte parce
que plus la vie est longue plus on a
envie on va pas faire 20 ans de plus la
même chose donc on change de partenaire
63% des bébés naissent leur mariage 63%
des bébés naissent en mariage je sais
pas si vous le savez vraiment on change
de partenaire on déménage on change de
conviction on change de métier etc on
est là dedans et donc la pandémie nous
offre une alternale
une accélération de ce processus avec un
million de couples qui ont explosé 2
millions 3 millions de Français qui ont
déménagé etc alors le tourisme là-dedans
ce qu'on a vu pendant la pandémie c'est
que quand on enlève le tourisme la ville
s'arrête parce qu'effectivement le
tourisme c'est le cœur du lien social de
la société moderne on n'est plus dans
des sociétés où les gens habitent à un
endroit tout le temps puisque à Paris
par exemple le nombre de nuitées où les
Parisiens ne dorment pas dans la ville
et le même que le nombre de nuités des
touristes dans la ville c'est à dire que
les touristes viennent beaucoup à Paris
évidemment mais en réalité vu que le nom
de l'unité ou les Parisiens sont pas
dans leur ville parce qu'ils sont en
vacances ils sont en weekend etc en fait
le total est égal à zéro pas en chiffre
d'affaires les touristes dépensent plus
que l'habitant parisien tous les jours
mais en nombre de nuité c'est pour
donner les masses si vous voulez qui
sont absolument considérés bien donc on
est dans ce dans ce mouvement de fond et
je crois qu'il faut se poser des
questions d'abord si vous en se disant
quel est notre objectif culturel et
politique je crois qu'il faut dire que
il faut continuer à développer le voyage
développer le tourisme développer la
découverte de l'autre c'est ce qui peut
nous permettre de faire une
mondialisation pas trop guerrière pour
le dire comme ça je pense si vous voulez
que le voyage on va pas revenir à
Montaigne etc c'est un élément central
de phénomène de paix social et de paix
politique je dirais aussi que l'absence
de voyage pendant deux ans à mon avis
accentué les conflits que ça soit dans
les couples avec un million de
séparation mais même les conflits
militaires les sociétés se sont repliées
sur elles-mêmes les gens se sont repliés
sur le local et donc effectivement on
montait renforcé les nationalismes etc
donc il y a un rapport entre tous ces
phénomènes
ça c'est la toile de fond donc notre
objectif il me semble qu'on doit définir
c'est que le voyage doit se développer
moi je vous donnerai deux objectifs
chiffrés je dirais il faut 80 % des
Français qui partent en vacances comme
objectif de 2050 il faut demi-heure et
demi touristes internationaux
c'est-à-dire je poserai d'abord
l'objectif en terme culturel en termes
sociales évidemment avec les
conséquences économiques qu'on peut voir
la question après c'est ils vont où ils
partent quand et comme on fait pour pas
être en situation de sur tourisme
partout mais il faut pas mélanger des
pointes sur tourisme on va tous citer
Barcelone Venise même avec les problèmes
de la mauvaise régulation d'Airbnb c'est
d'ailleurs plutôt le fait des mairies
parce que la loi est très claire et donc
si vous voulez des mairies enfin des
collègues des scènes sur le Airbnb c'est
la location de son appartement quand on
n'y est pas c'est la loi est très clair
sauf que c'est pas ça qui se passe
toujours il y a pas son et donc si vous
voulez ce processus et le Airbnb je vais
une parenthèse ça a eu un rôle décisif
dans l'état de la diffusion du tourisme
la zone rurale un de nos gros problèmes
c'est justement la diffusion du tourisme
donc Airbnb moi je vois qui habite à la
campagne dans tous les villages ça a
complètement changé la sociologie des
gens dans les bars les restaurants etc
donc il faut pas oublier on voit que le
Airbnb dans les zones de surtourisme le
Airbnb c'est aussi le touriste qui ne va
pas dans les hauts lieux qui se diffuse
donc c'est évidemment des cartes
importantes donc on est sur tous ces
phénomènes si on est d'accord avec les
objectifs après on se pose effectivement
la question de la régulation la
régulation si vous voulez moi j'ai
travaillé avec les jambes Barcelone pour
faire le bouquin
au début ils ont été élu contre le
tourisme contre le sur tourisme en
réalité et puis ils sont rendu compte de
quoi ils sont rendus compte c'est parce
qu'il y avait aucune politique tous les
gens ne veulent pas aller au même
endroit il y a des gens qui viennent en
voyage d'affaires tous les ans ceux-là
ils ont ils ont une certaine idée de la
ville il y a des gens qui sont dans les
campings sur la Costa Brava ils veulent
aller une journée sur les remplaces de
ce qu'ils veulent c'est manger sur les
Ramblas là ça pouvoir dire j'ai été
manger sur les Ramblas il y en a
d'autres qui font des visites
touristiques etc donc comment on diffuse
ces flux comment on fait pour qu'il soit
pas au même endroit comment régule
c'est-à-dire comment on met de
l'intelligence dans le tourisme au
premier problème du tourisme c'est qu'il
y a pas de recherche il y a pas de
connaissances les il n'y a pas de rde
dans les entreprises donc on déplace
quand le gouvernement français annoncé
100 millions de touristes en France mais
où qui quand on s'en fout c'est une
quantité c'est un chiffre d'affaire on
peut pas déplacer 100 millions de
personnes sans avoir une vraie stratégie
bon ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que
si on ne crée pas une haute école des
voyages où on se mettra enfin à
réfléchir à ces questions j'ai
représenté la France à Bruxelles à un
moment auprès du commissaire sur les
questions du tourisme autour de moi il y
avait tous les pays d'Europe ce n'était
que des techniciens les uns à expliquer
comment ranger une table les autres
comment nettoyer un restaurant etc
purement des techniciens on est en
France les seuls avoir une petite
prémisse de réflexion sur ces sujets on
ne pourra pas déplacer deux mille arrêt
de mégions sans réfléchir et les lieux
de surtension sont souvent des lieux de
nonobservation et donne un intelligence
des processus ben ça je crois que c'est
la première remarque la deuxième
remarque c'est que si on veut diffuser
les touristes dans le temps qui est une
question essentielle moi je plaide pour
ce que la semaine italienne condamne à
toutes les familles françaises le droit
de partir une semaine avec leurs enfants
quand ils veulent j'avais dans un enfant
à la grippe il vient pas pendant une
semaine c'est fondre pas sa vie si
effectivement vous autorisez toutes les
familles à partir une semaine à
contre-saison c'est quand les prix sont
beaucoup plus bas et effectivement quand
le mettons il y a un des deux parents
qui a un voyage d'affaires ou qui je
sais pas et que du coup ça s'intègre
avec des déplacements familiaux ce que
font les Italiens vous cassez par
exemple l'obligation de faire des
vacances étalées en février les gens qui
veulent aller au ski les 7% de Français
qui font du ski ils prendront leur
semaine à ce moment-là on n'est pas
obligé d'emmerder tous les Français je
vous le rappelle que la plupart des
familles françaises vivent sur plusieurs
départements souvent plusieurs régions
donc quand on étale les vacances de
février ça veut dire qu'on peut pas
réunir les cousins ça veut dire ça tout
simplement je vous rappelle que 50% des
français seulement vivent dans leur
département de naissance 50%. donc la
vraie société française c'est une
société de flux où il y a une partie de
stock mais qui est minoritaire et donc
les skate j'ai fait partie de la
commission qui régulait les temps de
vacances donc c'est des sujets que
j'avais vu quand je travaillais quai de
mon maire si vous voulez je pense que ça
il vaut mieux aujourd'hui donner une
semaine de libre choix et du coup
regrouper les vacances familiales de
Pâques etc qu'à nouveau les familles se
réunissent qu'à nouveau les
grands-parents puissent accueillir leurs
petits-enfants et qu'on arrête se
découpage pour 7 % français qui font du
ski qui en plus c'est quand même pas
injurieux pour les 93% qu'ils peuvent
pas se le payer vous voyez ces choses là
elles doivent bouger donc il y a cette
question faire de la formation créer
cette semaine de liberté du temps je
pense que ça serait une mesure très
populaire et en plus effectivement très
favorable par exemple au ski pour aller
au ski en dehors des vacances scolaires
du ski c'est qu'il faut y aller quand il
y a de la neige la neige n'est pas
toujours au même moment bien vous avez
ça donc ça c'est la première question
c'est la diffusion dans le temps si vous
voulez après vous avez
un problème de diffusion dans l'espace
il y a à peu près 15% de la planète qui
est touristique donc on a énormément
d'endroits qui ne sont pas touristiques
prenez Paris Notre-Dame de Notre-Dame de
Paris est très touristique mais la
basilique de Seine-Saint-Denis à
personne donc si vous voulez la grosse
question qu'on a c'est si on comprend le
voyage prenez le tourisme international
et qui vient en France mettons les 100
millions qui sont notre objectif même si
on n'est pas encore en fait ils viennent
la première fois ils visitent les lieux
qui connaissent avant de venir en gros
Paris la Savoie et la Côte d'Azur c'est
les trois lieux de leur imaginaire
mondiale de la France bien la question
qu'on a c'est comment on fait pour que
le deuxième ou le troisième voyage ne
soit pas à cet endroit là donc comment
quand il voyage dans ces trois
territoires là on va les informer sur la
beauté de la Bretagne sur le charme de
Bordeaux sur les Pyrénées etc
c'est-à-dire comment on construit le
deuxième voyage pendant le premier et
ainsi de suite dire comment on considère
le plus riche comme un être intelligent
à qui on donne de la matière pour le
diffuser dans l'espace pour le touriste
international c'est assez facile donc on
le fait pas pour le touristes français
il est clair que la plupart des gens
vont toujours au même endroit il est
clair que vous savez que 50% des
français ne se baignent que sur une
seule plage toute leur vie donc la
réalité c'est que c'est pas une foule
qui part dans tous les coins un
Marseillais va quasiment jamais en
Bretagne un bordelais va quasiment
jamais sur la Côte d'Azur vous prenez
Toulouse Toulouse c'est intéressant les
bourgeois si je peux me permettre de les
taper ainsi vont tous sur la côte
atlantique et les populaires vont tout
sur la Méditerranée Sylvie je vous
rappelle que Jaurès si vous vous
rappelez vous allez toujours sur la
Méditerranée parce qu'il voulait faire
populaire mais que les élites de
Toulouse vont beaucoup plus un Arcachon
donc si vous voulez le territoire du
tourisme est très structuré sauf qu'on
ne prend pas la peine de l'observer mais
il est extrêmement structuré je vous
rappelle quand que les gens de messe et
de Nancy ne vont pas en vacances au même
endroit parce qu'au moment le plus
résumé est devenu à la mode mais ce
n'était pas français donc du coup ils
sont pas partis en vacances donc les
règles aujourd'hui vont plutôt dans le
Languedoc les jantes Nancy bon
effectivement davantage sur la Côte
d'Azur on a tous ces flux très
intelligents très construit qu'on ne va
pas changer et qui sont des fluxches
qu'on peut un peu on peut les faire un
peu bouger mais cela vont notamment être
bouleversés par le télétravail parce que
justement ce sont les mêmes et en ce
moment ce qui se passe c'est d'une part
que beaucoup de gens il y a trois
modèles en ce moment il y a à peu près 2
millions de gens qui ont déménagé on
sait pas très bien on verra à la fin je
suis prudent dans les chiffres il y a
surtout beaucoup de résidences
secondaires qui restent 4 jours en
résidence secondaire ils partent le
jeudi entre le mardi donc ils font ce
temps double découper et puis il y a
beaucoup de gens de 50 ans qui achètent
massivement des maisons dans les grandes
régions touristiques parce qu'ils
anticipent leur retraite de 10 ans en se
disant bon vu la pandémie écoute on va
acheter la maison maintenant on avait
l'intention d'acheter et puis bon on va
faire les trajets pendant quelques
années on va faire du télétravail on va
garder qu'un boulot sur deux etc vous
prenez mon cabine dans le Luberon depuis
je suis petit tout est vendu hors de
prix dans la journée
tout est toujours le même modèle un
Parisien qui arrive et qui dit j'ai un
million qu'est-ce que vous avez nous on
était habitué à parler à 4 ou 500000
euros donc effectivement les maisons
sont vendues sur Internet vous mettez
votre maison en photo sur Internet dans
la journée les gens téléphone vous avez
demandé 500000 je vous propose 700 vous
me donnez à 700 et il monte les prix
alors que traditionnellement en France
on a plutôt tendance à déceler les prix
quoi ça ce sont des gens d'une
cinquantaine d'années qui en font
anticiper leur retrait dans un nouveau
rapport l'espace donc on a tout ça qui
joue si vous voulez donc
le tourisme de proximité a profité de la
pandémie les gens sont plus salés dans
leur territoire de proximité il y a un
petit marché je pense là que les
professionnels pourraient saisir c'est
l'essentiel des touristes l'essentiel
des résidences secondaires soit à moins
de 2 heures de la résidence principale
le modèle de la résidence secondaire
c'est pas Saint-Tropez il y en a
évidemment mais qui veut dire la grande
quantité regardez les Parisiens ils en
ont beaucoup en Bourgogne valait de la
Loire Normandie évidemment etc l'intérêt
de la secondaire c'est de pouvoir y
aller assez souvent donc vous avez c'est
ce nuage autour de chacune des vies donc
vous êtes sur tout ça après si vous
voulez ce qui est clair c'est qu'il y a
une montée de la demande de nature dans
nos sociétés les gens veulent voir du
verre je dirais on pourrait schématique
ils veulent entendre les oiseaux ce qui
d'un côté peut se faire dans la ville si
nos villes deviennent des immenses forts
et urbaines le rapport des gens à la
ville va changer alors est-ce qu'on va
mettre les millions d'arbres qu'on a
promis aux dernières élections
municipales tous les élus avaient prévu
des forêts absolument grandioses pour
l'instant on voit pas la plantation
commencer il est clair que la ville de
demain sera une forêt parce que c'est ce
qu'il faut je rappelle qu'un arbre c'est
quatre climatiseurs d'équivalent
fraîcheur donc si vous voulez il est
clair que vous mettez un million
d'arbres vous avez un effet d'économie
d'énergie considérable et vous baissez
la température de la ville on va vers ça
plus la ville va être verte plus la vie
leur a des rues en voiture etc plus
effectivement les gens vont m'en sortir
donc toutes les choses sont inséparables
les unes des autres c'est pour ça qu'il
faut regarder les choses en disant il
n'y a pas le tourisme qui a la
transhumance d'été c'est à dire un
trajet rituel qui dure en moyenne 15
jours alors les milieux populaires
régulent la durée en fonction de l'année
financière on va dire des fois il faut
qu'une semaine s'ils n'ont pas de sous
des fois ils font 15 jours entiers des
fois dix jours les populations plus
aisées c'est-à-dire en gros les 30% de
Français qui ont généralement aussi des
résidences secondaires eux ils vont
partir plusieurs fois ils font pas
forcément des séjours plus longs alors
je vous rappelle que quand on a créé le
Club Med le séjour minimum était deux
mois parce que le but était de
construire des amitiés et des liens
sociaux aujourd'hui le club MEDGE était
conseillé le Président on accepte des
gens 3 jours avec l'impact écologique
parce qu'on va à Djerba en avion pour
que le week-end donc ça évidemment tous
ces effets là c'est à dire que
l'objectif a complètement changé bien
donc il y a tout ça qui est dans ce
rapport à la nature qui effectivement le
fait qu'il faut le tour est une
proximité légites ruraux qui marchent le
mieux en France sont par exemple ce
Dourdan ce d'Île-de-France légitluro qui
marche le mieux sont ceux qui sont on
peut y aller j'allais dire en RER ou
faut pas croire que c'est l'Aubrac qui
marche le mieux même si l'Aubrac la zone
de France
chômage mais il faut dire qu'il y a pas
beaucoup d'habitants on est sur tous ces
bouleversements là si vous voulez et la
dernière chose que je vous dirais comme
c'est un introduction
vous prenez par exemple l'exemple du
Louvre il faut réserver ou la Tour
Eiffel par numérique prenez l'exemple de
la 4200
ou effectivement il faut s'inscrire ça
marche très bien on est passé de 2000
entrées à ce gitan à 400 par la
régulation et les gens sont contents ils
sont contents pourquoi ben parce que
quand ils arrivent à y aller ils sont
c'est sympa 400 assujitant c'est bien
2000 non seulement ça détruit
l'écosystème etc mais en terme humain ça
a aucun intérêt on peut pas s'asseoir
du tout intéressant donc là il y a des
mesures il faut dire quoi il faut
construire la France numérique du
tourisme il faut que si je veux aller
mettons je sais pas dans n'importe quel
endroit même dans le vrac au mois d'août
je vais taper puis je vais dire voilà je
voudrais aller sur l'Aubrac du premier
au 10 août on va vous dire à Monsieur à
ce moment-là excusez-nous les hôtels
sont complets les restaurants sont
pleins on vous conseille soit de venir
du 10 de la semaine d'après soit on a
une autre proposition offert un autre
endroit où il y aura beaucoup moins de
monde c'est aussi beau vous connaissez
pas on vous offre cette destination donc
il faut construire la France numérique
et si vous voulez je crois que c'est
absolument essentiel pour diffuser les
populations mais aussi parce que les
gens sont pas forcément contents quand
ils arrivent et que c'est bourré qu'il y
a pas moyen d'avoir de place au
restaurant etc je veux dire c'est pas
non plus agréable de comme type de alors
il y a des gens qui aiment bien là tu le
mélange pas les plages les plages je
pense que les gens aiment bien être
nombreux ou pas le discours de la plage
non solitaire c'est pas à mon avis c'est
pas une vérité sociale
qu'on a 4 millions de piscines donc il y
a aussi effectivement 4 millions de
piscines dites-vous que chaque piscine
doit bien au moins baigner 10 personnes
dans l'année 4 millions de piscine ça
veut dire la majorité des Français se
baignent chaque année dans une piscine
en réalité tout d'un copain d'un ami et
d'anniversaire des enfants etc il faut
bien avoir une piscine c'est pas chacun
sa piscine si c'est un objet familial et
qui sert notamment intégré les membres
de copains donc ça évidemment cette
fonction sociale extrêmement importante
donc voilà si tous ces éléments qui sont
mais ce que je vous dis là en même temps
et je m'arrête là dessus c'est ce que je
vous ai dit au début on pourra pas
continuer à développer le tourisme et en
faire une des principales ressources de
l'économie française on est bientôt au
niveau du poids économique de
l'industrie alors c'est dramatique pour
l'industrie mais je veux dire que son
année à peu près là j'espère qu'un
industrie arrivera à remonter mais ce
n'est pas le cas et si on ne veut pas
mettre de l'intelligence si on ne doit
pas observer si on ne veut pas
construire cette France numérique qui
fait que quand je veux aller à l'endroit
on va tout de suite me donner des
conseils ou pas etc et Pam et
éventuellement me conseiller d'aller
vous me direz écoutez voilà cette
semaine là non vous pouvez pas aller à
la calanque de Sugiton mais par contre à
partir du 15 août je peux vous réserver
une place prenez le Louvre est-ce que
c'est très grave si on vous quand vous
voulez aller au Louvre on dit écoutez
monsieur en 22 il y a plus de place mais
on peut vous trouver une très bonne
place en 23 vous allez y aller combien
dans votre vie au lourd si vous allez
l'année prochaine le monde vous tombe
pas sur la tête et il y a beaucoup de
choses qui sont de cette nature là on
peut diffuser dans ce temps on peut
après il y a une autre chose qu'il faut
dire le Louvre ça fait 20 ans que je
râle pourquoi le Louvre n'est pas ouvert
7 jours sur 7 et pourquoi il y a pas des
nuits je veux dire que l'idée que des
milliards d'argent investis dans l'art
sont bloqués par des structures
salariales et syndicales pourquoi
Eurodisney est ouvert tous les jours et
pas le Louvre vous ouvrez le Louvre vous
l'ouvrez jusqu'à minuit vous faites des
nuits entières mais je veux dire vous
avez un fait de diffusion et
d'entraînement d'emploi que touristique
absolument important donc si oui il
faudrait aussi qu'on considère le
patrimoine culturel de la France comme
une valeur et donc la question de son us
et plus large est un enjeu absolument
majeur donc si vous le Louvre est un
excellent exemple et moi j'adore chaque
fois chaque fois qu'il y a un nouveau
ministre du Tourisme je lui dis est-ce
que vous êtes capable d'ouvrir le Louvre
tous les jours ils me disent tous oui
aucun il est arrivé parce qu'il y a des
blocs à gênant
ah non c'est pas possible et cetera et
Euro Disney il y arrive très bien donc
si vous voulez pourquoi le privé c'est
géré quelque chose en continu que le
public ne serait pas faire alors qu'un
investissement est tellement énorme en
oeuvre d'art oui je l'ai trouvé purement
business là voilà il y a un peu tout ça
donc ma conclusion c'est si on ne
réfléchit pas plus c'est un secteur qui
ne va créer que des surtensions et des
conflits on est dans la situation où on
lâche en France 100 millions de
touristes étrangers et 180 millions de
Français en France qui circulent un peu
comme si on allait sur les autoroutes
sans qu'il y ait de code de la route ni
de vitesse régulée on lâche tout ça puis
on dirait les illégales rapportez-nous
du pognon mais non l'homme peut pas
déplacer les gens comme ça et je pense
si vous voulez qu'on est là sur des des
problèmes d'organisation c'est pour ça
j'ai dit au début 80% des départs en
français des Français en vacances et
demi à la limite touristes si on est sur
l'objectif après comment gère les flux
et comment les régule c'est ça la
question qui nous est posée et dans des
conditions agréables pour le touriste
parce que quand vous avez fait des
heures de queue sur l'autoroute et tout
je veux dire vous voyez et puis les
stations il va falloir lutter d'un point
de vue écologique quand est-ce que les
grandes stations vous aurez des parkings
à l'extérieur parce que les gens
circulent avec leur voiture c'est plus
commode mais ce que je peux la laisser à
l'extérieur de la ville est-ce qu'on me
file des vélos électriques et ce qui est
un système de transport de mes bagages
jusqu'à l'hôtel est-ce que tout ça est
complètement pensé la logistique on est
mauvais on n'a pas de ministère de la
logistique c'est vrai dans tous les
secteurs c'est 10% de l'emploi et en
France on est encore sur les découpages
ministériels de d'après-guerre il y a
plein de pays qui ont des ministres de
la logistique or le tourisme c'est
d'abord un problème de logistique si on
veut lutter d'un point de vue écologique
l'essentiel de la pollution du tourisme
c'est le déplacement donc je voulais du
coup effectivement là on est face à une
question tout à fait essentielle mais
qu'est-ce qu'on a comme politique
là-dessus les gens n'iront pas avec
trois enfants des bagages en train en
vacances je crois que ça sera jamais
majoritaire parce que j'ai compliqué
parce que la voiture c'est génial on met
les enfants les ballons le chien etc bon
mais après on n'est pas obligé de s'en
servir à l'autre bout donc comment
est-ce qu'on fait pour que nos stations
se systématiquement équipées électrique
pour qui est systématiquement les
systèmes de transport des bagages pour
qu'il y ait des parkings surveillés
parce que les touristes qui veulent pas
c'est que la voiture ne soit pas
surveillée combien de villes françaises
ont des parkings surveillés pour les
touristes moi j'ai été élu à Marseille
je suis même pas arrivé à le faire alors
que quand quelqu'un est avec des bagages
pour visiter une ville son premier
problème c'est la sécurité de ses
bagages question quand même très
légitime combien de parkings surveillés
dans les villes françaises quasiment
jamais vous voyez surtout ces problèmes
et je parle même pas de l'arrivée à
Roissy c'est une catastrophe parce que
les plans de travail d'éloignés et les
plans de travail effectivement des
compagnies aériennes ne sont pas à gérer
de la même manière chacun a son projet
alors des fois on attend deux heures des
fois on n'attend pas des fois la peine
douaniers il y a pas de touristes je
veux dire on est quand même dans un mode
de sous-organisation qui nous coûte
extrêmement cher et à mon avis qui gâche
beaucoup la vie des gens donc si on veut
progresser il faudrait mettre tout ça
sur la table
merci
ben écoutez merci c'est sont des propos
très très intéressants qui qui nous
interpelle
notamment l'organisation du tourisme et
en France très territorialisée puisque
on a des comités régionaux de tourisme
comité départementaux chaque commune
veut faire son son
comment s'appelle son office de tourisme
c'est difficile pour une commune
d'organiser justement faire la promotion
de son territoire et puis dire aux gens
ne venez pas en même temps et aller voir
dans le territoire d'à côté c'est aussi
beau que chez nous donc ça veut dire que
est-ce que il faut une
dans votre théorie
un découpage administratif enfin pas
administratif mais un découpage de la
politique touristique différent par
rapport à celui que l'on connaît
le problème c'est que les élus locaux
vous savez que moi il y a 20 ans les
lieux tourisme c'était un général à
monsieur qui présentait bien peut âgé
qui aimait bien les cocktails etc en
gros ça c'était les lots et puis petit à
petit on s'est rendu compte que c'était
un vrai secteur économique et que ça
avait un enjeu réel le problème si vous
voulez c'est qu'au fond c'est un secteur
de valorisation des élus de l'image de
l'élite parce qu'il est dans les médias
etc logiquement le tourisme est
travaillé par destination touristique
les touristes ils vont en Provence
esquisses que Arles Aix-en-Provence et
Marseille en fait c'est tout c'est des
secteurs différents alors le type qui va
Harle il est juste à côté l'exambre avec
quand est-ce qu'on va lui vendre tout ça
en même temps si vous voulez donc c'est
ça qui est compliqué c'est que
historiquement il y a tous ces
découpages administratifs mais qui ne
correspondent pas à la France du
tourisme la France du tourisme est
structurée par des destinations vous
avez la Côte d'Azur vous avez la
Provence etc et donc ça dépend à quel
marché on parle si on parle au marché
local ce qui se passe c'est plutôt bien
dans les offices du tourisme s'occupent
aussi souvent de faire partir les locaux
ils ont pas seulement une fonction
d'accueil donc ils ont les deux
fonctions ça dépend quel marché le
marché international je vous ai dit il
travaille en gros sur trois items Paris
là savoir et la Côte d'Azur donc eux ils
ont besoin de prouver des objets à la
taille je dirais de leur vision du monde
en train de trouver un office savoir
parce que c'est pareil Côte d'Azur si
vous leur dites
pas Alpes-Maritimes pour eux c'est du
chinois si vous leur dites Var c'est du
chinois d'ailleurs l'étape d'Azur bon
mort sur une partie on va dire on va
mettre jusqu'à Saint-Tropez au moins
vous voyez on n'est pas dans les mêmes
espaces donc fondamentalement pour un
type qui travaille sur le tourisme il a
envie qu'on dessine la France
touristique tu as des la France des
imaginaires touristiques pour aller
chercher s'adresser aux gens voilà mais
après je sais tous les enjeux qu'il y a
je pense qu'il y a trop de découpage
locaux je comprends que les communes et
des offices je pense que les têtes que
les départements pourraient arrêter de
s'occuper de ça ça serait pas dramatique
parce que on va pas dans un département
et un en Bretagne on va en Bretagne on
ne sait pas si c'est la limite entre le
Morbihan et le Finistère moi j'ai une
maison en Bretagne je suis dans le
Finistère mais c'est pas évident pour
tout le monde donc je crois que là
dessus on pourrait effectivement
réfléchir
bien merci merci pour vos propos
effectivement limères
vous vous pointez dans votre ouvrage et
vous venez de le redire ce matin
l'importance sociale du tourisme et
l'altruisme qui permet de développer
donc la nécessité qu'il y ait des
politiques publiques et je crois que
vous l'avez démontré sur sur la fin et
compris des les transformer de
certainement les réinventer pour pour
mieux répondre d'abord à la demande du
touriste mais aussi au retombées sur un
territoire donné qu'elle conçoit
d'ailleurs sa taille ou sont découpage
pour avoir aussi ces retombées
économiques que qu'apporte le tourisme
dans notre pays je crois que vous disiez
un peu plus de 10% du PIB de la France
pour
sur le tourisme et pour autant une
absence totale de politique même de
ministères de pleine exercices en la
matière je voulais revenir sur y compris
le dernier exemple que que vous venez
auquel vous faites référence qui est un
peu cette imaginaire touristique que
peuvent avoir alors bien évidemment des
populations étrangères que l'on peut
avoir nous-mêmes en bon français
alors il faut à la fois la satisfaire
comment est-ce que du coup on ne tombe
pas dans un seul modèle qui empêcherait
justement à découvrir d'autres choses
que simplement cette imaginaire dans
lequel nous pourrions être conditionnés
alors vous l'avez dit avec des grands
flux historiques selon son milieu social
ou son lieu d'habitation comment est-ce
que les politiques publiques sont casser
cette imaginaire qui demeure un après
peuvent contribuer en tout cas à faire
découvrir d'autres d'autres lieux et
comment vous voyez alors vous l'avez dit
à travers par exemple de vous le prenez
à travers l'exemple de la ville de
Barcelone mais de quel type de politique
publique peut être plus local il y
aurait besoin puisque finalement sur
centouriste chacun a des attentes des
consommations des divertissements des
occupations différentes sur un même
temps donné donc là peut-être plus le
quel rôle pourrait avoir bien évidemment
les élus et les acteurs économiques pour
pour satisfaire ces différents besoins
et ainsi dans une même destination en
tout cas diversifier l'offre et les
personnes accueillies
la première chose c'est que il faut bien
se dire qu'on organise pas le tourisme
pour nous chacun d'entre nous a décidé
très précises moi vous voyez j'adore
aller sur l'Aubrac mais je sais très
bien que c'est pas là où elle allait la
plus majorité des français donc il faut
faire il faut partir du désir des
touristes et pas de la représentation
qu'on peut avoir en tant qu'élu tout ça
moi j'ai été vice-président dans ses
réponses métropole donc je vois bien
comment ça fonctionne à ce niveau-là ça
c'est la première chose à dire la
deuxième chose c'est qu'il faut si
différentier le voyage de ce que
j'appelle la transhumance je veux dire
que le voyage où vous voulez découvrir
une ville où vous voulez aller chez pas
New York à Istanbul à Marseille le
voyage d'ailleurs vous le faites
généralement j'allais dire à fond les
enfants et après les enfants donc ces
deux périodes de la vie différente du
coup c'est pas les mêmes clientèles
c'est pas le même âge voyez par exemple
je prenais les camping-cars l'écart de
jeunes qui dorment dedans maintenant ils
ont pas des camping-cars ils ont des
camions aménagés c'est plutôt avant les
enfants etc donc il faut ce clivage de
l'âge qui élément important et dans le
clivage au milieu il y a la grande
question des familles c'est la sécurité
des enfants donc il faut jamais
l'oublier ce qui fait le succès de VVF
ce qui fait succès du Club Med de Center
Parcs même si c'est jamais dit
clairement c'est la sécurité puisque
c'est clos et que donc en gros vous a
rentré là vous arrivez avec votre enfant
vous êtes sûr de repartir avec ce qui
est quand même extrêmement intéressant
donc si vous voulez et vous avez pas
besoin de le surveiller tout le temps un
des grands succès des parcs c'est la
sécurité et c'est pour ça quand il y a
eu un accident que le maître dramatique
un enfant était noyé dans une piscine
pour eux c'était terrible parce que au
fond ce qui garantissait c'était une
sécurité à 100% bon et c'est normal tu
as fait légitime donc si vous voulez et
du coup c'est ce qui explique aussi que
ces équipements soient clos et que donc
il ne soit pas ouverts sur l'extérieur
ce qui vaut aussi pour les par exemple
les clubs Méditerranée qu'on avait au
Maghreb au Maroc etc qui n'était pas
ouvert sur la société extérieure donc
voyez il y a ça qu'il faut mettre un nom
bon il y a tout ça je rajouterai une
chose je n'ai pas dit c'est comment on
arrive à 80% oui qui ne part pas en
vacances si vous voulez c'est une
question importante parce que donc qui
ne part pas en vacances il y a
évidemment une partie du ouvrier mais il
m'y ouvrier pas de Paris on part
beaucoup plus dans les grandes villes
que dans les petites il y a un groupe
social qui est très défavorisé ce sont
les femmes seules notamment avec enfants
vous savez qu'il y en a à peu près un
million 700000 avec à peu près 200
millions d'enfants donc c'est un groupe
social très important parce que on va
dire les choses simplement moi quand
j'ai conseillé de mon maire à la quand
il a privé VF et puis après je l'ai
conseillé le club mail on ne prenait pas
les femmes seules prenez pas pourquoi
parce que je m'excusé moi je mets des
guillemets par courtoisie évidemment ça
fout le bordel c'est pas les femmes
seules qui mettent le bordel c'est que
tous les hommes se disent pourquoi elle
est là celle-là toute seule et donc il y
a une pression masculine sur ces femmes
qui fait qu'on ne les prenait pas parce
que c'est un métier du désordre je vous
parle des années 80 il y a pas le
moyen-âge alors depuis on a un peu
changé les règles au Club Méditerranée
il y avait une surtax il payait plus
cher sur le thème de oui non mais elle
est plus valide de place elle est toute
seule donc ça coûte plus cher donc je
veux dire au fond c'est un problème
parce que c'est une population
importante c'est le groupe social qui
parle moins en vacances et souvent un
peu indépendamment de son niveau de
revenu alors après les vacances sont des
vacances de bande de famille donc très
souvent vous voyez des femmes seules qui
partent avec des frères des cousins des
amis donc elles sont pris dans un groupe
et pour aller dans les petits détails
vous voyez on a modifié par exemple au
Club Med des systèmes de réservation
vous pouvez demander trois chambres à
côté avant c'était pas possible
maintenant on a compris que les gens se
déplacent en tribu et donc il faut les
héberger en tri bon je ferme ma
parenthèse sur ces questions mais si
vous voulez c'est des questions
importantes après le problème c'est que
le territoire à la mode change prenez
Marseille grande destination touristique
actuelle moi j'étais vice-présent la
communauté urbaine je vous assure qu'on
ramait à l'époque il y avait en
développé les croisières difficiles mais
on n'a pas pensé à équiper le port en
plus électrique donc du coup quand les
croisés ont commencé à démarrer elles
ont pollué effectivement tout le
centre-ville parce que c'est gros bateau
alors soi-disant ils ont pas le même
produit pour brûler mazout là qui est
déjà est dégueulasse donc si vous voulez
regarder un marché à ce moment les
conflits la mairie voudrait qu'il y ait
plus de croisière alors que c'est quand
même millions de passagers pourquoi
parce qu'on n'a pas équipé le port et
donc quand les bateaux sont hackés ils
n'ont pas de prise électrique pour
charger alors on est en train de le
faire mais si vous voulez on ne s'est
battu pour faire les croisières mais on
n'a pas prévu que au fur et à mesure il
fallait les équipements pour que la
population locale n'est pas l'impression
qu'on a pu anticiper de façon
épouvantable vous voyez tous ces
processus et Marseille donc est à la
mode alors pendant longtemps quand on
vendait la province on mettait pas
Marseille parce que personne ne voulait
aller à Marseille et donc ce qu'on
vendait c'était ex et Arles et on
vendait alors cette Provence là etc on
prenait un petit bout de Pagnol mais
c'était plutôt quand on allait de
l'autre côté vers Aubagne donc on
découpait le territoire parce qu'on
savait que si on disait Marcel les gens
venaient plus tellement ils avaient peur
les Belges qu'on a de Marseille c'est
les bandits c'est tout ça et tout la
drogue etc d'ailleurs existe et
malheureusement s'entretuent pour des
problèmes de drogue mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que actuellement la ville est
très attractive pourquoi elle est très
attractive je vais vous dire très
clairement je mets des guillemets à mes
mots parce que c'est le bordel voilà
c'est à dire que je peux les gens
cherchent à Marseille c'est une société
un peu moins léchée un peu moins
organisée un peu plus souple un peu on
peut se garer sur les trottoirs etc
c'est à dire il y a cette abstraction
pour une ville de métissage etc de
mouvement dans un pays qui est en train
de se normaliser sur tous les
comportements les machins la longueur
des pantalons etc donc c'est à fond
c'est quasiment une le côté je dirais ce
qu'il faisait le rejet de Marseille il
fait son attractivité et en ce moment la
ville démarre à tout vitesse parce que
c'est aussi des milliers de gens qui
viennent habiter à Marseille de Paris
pour créer des startups et donc cette
ville est en train de devenir un
laboratoire des nouvelles technologies
extraordinaires bon je ferme ma
parenthèse mais c'est pour dire que la
carte n'est pas toujours la même et
qu'il faut l'observer cette carte
regardez le tourisme de la façade
atlantique ils ont été très intelligents
quand ils ont développé le tourisme dans
les années 80-90 il y en avait beaucoup
moins avant ils ont été piqués les
responsables du tourisme de Méditerranée
notamment la directrice du tourisme de
Méditerranée pourquoi parce que elle a
amené le savoir-faire et ils ont tout
développé sur la France authentique si
on dit la France authentique pour
l'Atlantique c'est sous-entendu que la
Méditerranée c'est le bronzu de l'Europe
donc c'est catégorie au fond on casse le
marché du voisin on est en concurrence
les uns avec les autres et il y a ce
processus après la
provençale-côte d'Azur est la principale
destination mais ça c'est beaucoup
développé regardez comment ils ont fait
des choses intelligentes non le Voyage à
Nantes me fascine c'est une innovation
magnifique ou d'un coup on met l'art
dans l'espace public et on fait visiter
la ville à des gens à travers l'art
c'est pas du tout l'art qu'on enferme
dans des musées ce qui était un modèle
19e siècle c'est le l'espace public avec
des œuvres d'art vivantes des spectacles
et tout et on attire et nantes est une
ville qui s'est relookée grâce au
tourisme le problème qui se pose puisque
on a le colloque qu'on a fait qui a fait
le livre c'était à Nantes ils se disent
mais ce qu'on va continuer à tirer du
monde parce qu'ils arrivent à un moment
la question du surtourisme les touches
je pense qu'ils ont encore de la marge
et enfin c'est un vrai problème vous
voyez on est pris dans ces processus
donc c'est évolutif donc non c'est
beaucoup développé Marseille est
extrêmement à la mode
est en train de contre-attaquer parce
qu'il s'était rendu compte qu'il s'était
un peu endormi en plus si vous voulez
vous avez derrière ça les flux de
retraités puisque aujourd'hui prendre sa
retraite c'est imaginaire des grandes
vacances après guerre prendre sa
retraite vous savez qu'en 45 l'espérance
de vie d'un traité était inférieur à 2
ou 3 ans donc au fond c'était plutôt je
reste à côté de ma famille pour les
derniers moments nous une dame qui prend
sa retraite à 29 ans de retraite donc
forcément ça devient un nouveau projet
de vie et ce projet de vie j'allais dire
à une époque les gens aisés à l'air
Cannes quand ils étaient vieux
aujourd'hui ils vont plutôt à
Montpellier parce qu'il y a un excellent
un peu plus tard et une vie culturelle
il y a la mère des tramway qui va à la
mer etc vous voyez là aussi un
déplacement des lieux attractifs qui se
fait donc pour répondre à votre question
d'abord il faut observer en permanence
ces évolutions et donc être capable de
gérer de déplacer les curseurs soit en
disant par exemple mais ça ne marcheurs
justement ça marche trop bien on ne met
pas la lampe parce que si on éclaire
Marseille ils vont être encore plus
saturés donc peut-être qu'il faut plus
en parler ou on peut le choix je veux
dire à sa discuter avec les locaux etc
en termes d'économique avec la Chambre
de commerce etc est-ce qu'on continue à
pousser sur Marseille ce que la ville
peut intégrer davantage le monde est-ce
que comme on gère cette question je
pense l'exemple parce que je le connais
bien mais c'est la même question qui se
pose un Nantes alors vous avez
effectivement d'autres territoires où il
y a beaucoup de plus de place je pense
que le Massif Central est un directeur
en pleine croissance touristique sur un
tourisme effectivement un peu différent
avec c'est pas les hôtels des années 50
c'est des Loges c'est des fermes en fait
c'est des cuisines locales c'est tout ça
c'est même en termes de camping-car la
concentration des camping-cars le jour
du départ de la transhumance du massif
de l'Aubrac c'est des centaines et des
centaines de camping-cars qui viennent
pour voir le départ de la transhumance
donc si vous voulez vous avez tous ces
nouvelles non ce que je veux vous dire
c'est que c'est tout ça est vivant et
que il y a ces vrais le fond on va la
première règle c'est on va toujours au
même endroit et la deuxième règle c'est
il y a des choses qui changent et c'est
là qu'il faut observer si je peux dire
les choses comme ça
[Musique]
merci monsieur le Président alors comme
vous êtes monsieur Viard comme vous avez
cité 5 fois ou six fois le braque je
suis le sénateur de l'Aubrac
je me félicite
j'avais une question par rapport au
tourisme durable
dans votre ouvrage vous dites par
rapport à l'engin environnemental il
faut repenser les choses vous l'avez un
peu expliqué et ma question ma question
porte
en vertu cette nouvelle conscience
écologique plus ou moins vertueuse dans
les pratiques ou de nouvelles envies
d'espace certains sites et certaines
destinations connaissent l'engouement de
touristes alors je vous prends un
exemple de l'Aubrac c'est l'exemple des
chemins de Saint-Jacques avec notamment
la voix du puits qui traverse le
Nord-Aveyron depuis l'Aubrac jusqu'à
quand que n'est-ce pas et jusqu'à en
Espagne qui connaît un succès
extraordinaire le Jura 65 plus de 30000
marcheurs par an et durant les années
covides le chemin a été pris d'assaut et
les hébergeurs ont pu voir arriver des
clientèles au profil nouveau il y aura
les règles des pratiques de grande
randonnée inexpérimentées et sans
connaissance réelle des contraintes des
espaces traversées
or le tourisme vert un espace rural
n'est pas forcément durable si on adapte
pas ces pratiques au site dans
lesquelles on se trouve donc tout en
étant dans une approche de développement
raisonnée c'est ma question dans ce
contexte de nouvelles conscience
écologique qui attire nouvelles
clientèle comment accompagner les
clientèles dans des pratiques durables
et protéger les espaces de tourisme
sensible et naturels de la pression de
d'une surf fréquentation inadaptée
comment donc à l'occurrence les chemins
de Saint-Jacques inscrit au patrimoine
mondial de l'UNESCO peuvent-ils
réellement
devenir un modèle de tourisme durable en
accord avec la valeur universelle
exceptionnelle intrinsèque au chemin
voilà c'était ma question
oui je connais bien je veux bien quand
on passe par saint-Urcisse tout ça je
vois tout à fait bien et d'ailleurs
c'est marrant parce que sur le bras
qu'on a vu les hôtels évoluer même
pendant la pandémie parce que on n'a pas
parlé du personnel des tourisme et des
hôteliers et tout ça mais ils sont en
train de changer leur pratique parce
qu'ils sont rendus compte qu'au fond ils
pouvaient vivre en travers en ayant une
vie normale c'est-à-dire de pas
travailler tous les soirs tous les
week-ends
si vous connaissez chez Fred à l'hôtel
effectivement à côté de cette durcisse
vous avez effectivement des pratiques le
soir ils laissent les gens libre service
et les gens se font la cuisine dans
l'hôtel et eux du coup ils sont plus là
donc il y a des tas d'évolution des
pratiques pour respecter un peu la vie
privée des salariés qui est complètement
abîmée et après vous avez raison c'est
une vraie question alors après pendant
la pandémie on a eu affaire à des
touristes qui sont venus là parce que
s'ils pouvaient pas aller loin donc ils
avaient une logique de proximité il
avait pas forcément un choix d'aller
faire les chemins si vous voulez donc là
on a eu des vagues de touristes j'allais
dire un peu inadapté au territoire parce
que il tout simplement parce qu'il
voulait rester à côté de chez eux si
jamais ils étaient malades ils pouvaient
vous voulez courir va leur médecin
habituel je comprends très bien donc je
dirais c'est un cas un peu particulier
mais je suis d'accord avec vous le
problème de la surdensité c'est chaque
territoire une capacité absorbée la
salle la calanque de sugit-on on avait
décidé que c'était 400 personnes chez
les spécialistes du parc national qui
ont décidé ça mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que tous les territoires il y a
pas d'homogénéité et ça c'est vrai et
après si vous voulez il y a des
territoires comme ça je pense que le
tourisme vous savez comment c'est un des
lieux où il y a moins de chômage donc de
France il y a beaucoup de hache mais pas
seulement donc après comment
réfléchissent ces questions comment on
utilise les parcs comme outil de
régulation parce que il y a quand même
30 un peu plus presque 30% du territoire
français qui embarquent en réserve c'est
l'essentiel des territoires là il y a
des outils sur lequel on peut on peut
travailler il y a aussi le fait si vous
voulez que on a trop pensé les parcs
notamment comme des objets de protection
alors les parcs nationaux ça se discute
pas les parcs régionaux c'est complexe
mais moi je les ai suivis depuis le
départ j'ai l'âge de dire ça notamment
j'ai suivi le parc du Luberon puisque
moi j'étais enfant dans le Lubéron
j'habite toujours j'ai vu la
construction du parc successivement et
au fond paradoxalement plus on a
construit le parc plus on a segmenté les
publics parce que moi quand j'étais
enfant on montait manger en haut de la
montagne il y en a un qui monte avec la
2 chevaux les courses et les autres
monter à pied donc on a emmené les vieux
parce qu'on les mettait dans la 2
chevaux maintenant dans le Lubéron bah
il y a plus que des marcheurs ou des
chasseurs d'un âge sans enfant plutôt
qui sont en âge de monter dans la
montagne donc en gros je dirais qu'ils
ont entre 16 et 50 ans donc on a
finalement segmenté parce qu'on n'a pas
mis en place par exemple des parkings
gardés on n'a pas mis en place le fait
qu'il navette électrique ce qui existe
dans certains endroits pour monter les
gens au de la montagne et qui marchent
au sommet et pas qu'il fasse la pente
etc c'est à dire que si on veut enrichir
en emploi et donc en satisfaction des
habitants il y a tout ce travail de
détails qui doit être fait à chaque lieu
pourquoi dans le sommet des montagnes
comme ça il y a pas des restaurants
éphémères que bien sûr les plages pour
qu'on puisse monter déjeuner en buvant
etc donc vous voyez il y a toute cette
réflexion de la densification de
l'éphémère d'utilisation des outils de
régulation qui sont effectivement devant
nous après c'est compliqué parce que les
populations locales sont très
ambivalentes si vous voulez parce qu'à
la fois c'est de l'activité économique
il y en a qui vendent des cannes l'autre
des fromages etc il y en a qui font de
l'hébergement
il y a toutes ces pratiques là et en
même temps on a un sentiment
d'envahissement alors c'est compliqué
parce qu'en plus quand il arrive x
touristes il en reste toujours
quelques-uns c'est-à-dire que une partie
des habitants sont des nouveaux
habitants même prenez dans le vignoble
en France 45% des vignerons ne sont des
nouveaux installés ne sont pas des
paysans de longue lignée donc vous voyez
on est là sur ces processus qui
deviennent très importants notamment en
Provence et dans l'innovense donc je
dirais qu'il reste toujours quelque
chose d'un flux touristique dans la
population permanente y compris des
amours des voilà donc si vous voulez il
faut réfléchir à tout ça il faut montrer
il faut réfléchir à comment ça crée de
pour les gens quel type d'emploi est-ce
qu'il est qualifié est-ce qu'il est
qualifiant donc vous voyez c'est tous
ces sujets mais après je comprends très
bien qu'on puisse réguler je comprends
très bien qu'on peut faire ce chemin de
Compostelle ce que je vous raconte sur
ce gitan c'est pour ça que je plaise
pour une France numérique du tourisme
peut-être qu'un jour on s'inscrira sur
internet pour faire les chemins de
Saint-Jacques et ça c'est pas dramatique
de devoir aller l'année suivante ou de
voir décaler de 15 jours sans
déplacement donc si vous voulez je pense
qu'on échappera pas à une gestion
numérique du film ça je vais vous dire
une chose si on ne régule pas par le
numérique en régulera par le prix c'est
simple je veux dire qu'on a deux modèles
de régulation efficace ou cette exploser
les prix c'est ce que fait le bouton le
bouton je vous rappelle que chaque jour
vous dormez dans le pays vous payez 190
euros de taxes par nuitée donc forcément
ça limite la population on peut aller
vers des modèles comme ça où on peut
aller vers une régulation numérique des
flux mais en se posant aussi chaque fois
la question comment on peut densifier
l'activité comment on peut densifier
l'emploi comment les gens du pays
peuvent y gagner
[Musique]
merci François Bonneau
oui
oui François
je voulais vous poser une question par
rapport au patrimoine bâti la France
dispose d'un patrimoine bâtir
remarquable et s'ouvre semble-t-il d'un
double handicap c'est à dire que les
visites classiques ne fonctionnent plus
et d'autre part le réchauffement
climatique fait que les touristes
notamment quatre fois par an ne sont
plus du tout attirés par ces sites
compte tenues de des conditions dans
lesquelles le visiteur quels sont vous
vos préconisations par rapport par
rapport à un sujet qui est quand même
assez important en France puisqu'il est
il est quand même l'image de notre pays
comme lié aussi à ce patrimoine bâti
alors deux choses d'abord je pense qu'on
est un des pays au monde où on a le plus
réinvesti dans le patrimoine historique
je dirais le dernier lavoir du dernier
village a été restauré et là on a fait
un boulot depuis 50 ans considérable la
deuxième chose c'est qu'on est sans
doute un erreur pay au monde il y a des
touristes partout parce que si vous
voulez le tourisme s'est développé dans
l'ensemble des pays évidemment après la
grande période des flux industriels donc
dans l'originalité de la France c'est
qu'au moment de la révolution
industrielle les populations du Sud sont
montées pour faire la France
bureaucratique et industrielle qu'on a
connu effectivement début de 20e siècle
et puis dans la deuxième moitié du 20e
siècle ils sont redescendus sur la Côte
d'Azur dans les Cévennes etc c'est à
dire qu'on a un des rares pays où ce qui
avait été vidé a été réutilisé par le
tourisme on prenait l'Angleterre au nord
de Londres il y a pas de touristes vous
prenez l'Italie aussi de Rome il y en a
quasiment pas etc donc si vous voulez la
France a une immense chance là-dedans
c'est qu'elle a des pratiques sociales
de tourisme partout et d'ailleurs la
toile TGV illustre assez bien donc c'est
la première chose qu'il faut dire et qui
est un immense atout pour le patrimoine
la deuxième chose alors monsieur le
sénateur je connais bien la Charente je
vais tous les ans trois jours pour
visiter les petites églises surentes je
demande l'as jamais
mes chaque fois j'ai la même colère
quand je vais dans les CV dans les
Pyrénées de l'autre côté chez les
Espagnols j'achète un ticket pour
visiter toutes les églises du nord de
l'Espagne et avec ce ticket je visite
celle que je veux mais dans chaque
église avec ça il paye quelqu'un qui
peut m'expliquer l'église et qui fait la
sécurité pour qu'on vole pas les
affaires et donc il s'est accueillant il
y a quelqu'un etc j'ai payé pour visiter
le nom d'église que je veux c'est à dire
qu'ils ont fait une économie de la
gestion des églises en Charente elles
sont ouvertes où elles sont fermées ça
dépend un peu de l'humeur des gens et du
fait qu'on leur aura ou pas voler
quelque chose mais il y a pas de
tourisme or il est clair que les églises
de Charente sont une des merveilles du
patrimoine français mais en tant que
groupe pas celle-là plutôt que celle-là
bon et que je me dis la vitesse qu'on va
faire de cinq destination ou
effectivement il y aura des gens qui
viendront parce que c'est parmi les
territoire une densité de petites
églises de village très simple
absolument magnifique donc vous voyez
pour moi la destination elle est pas
construite il y a un patrimoine mais il
y a pas de projet donc effectivement ça
marche pas bon donc je prends cet
exemple je peux pas j'ai pas forcément
votre zone d'électorale donc je peux pas
du tout être agressif parce que je veux
dire c'est que souvent quand on se pose
ces questions si on fond parce qu'on a
pas de projet le tourisme c'est un
projet c'est un projet pour le
territoire c'est un projet vous savez la
mise en tourisme d'un territoire moi je
dis souvent c'est sa mise en désir
depuis la guerre les territoires qui
font rêver sur ce lieu du tourisme parce
que c'est l'autoroute qui communique
parce que c'est lui qu'on voit dans les
films etc etc au fond le tourisme c'est
une machine à mise en désir des lieux et
donc prenez un exemple simple j'aurais
pas désagréable mais quand madame Bardot
sera morte ça tombe sur une destination
touristique ça pourrait être un objet
pour un territoire donc si vous voulez
comme on est la tombe de Camus à
lourmande ou la tombe de jeune homme
Manosque donc si vous voulez ça et donc
effectivement c'est ça sur quoi je
voudrais insister il me semble que si on
regarde les choses comme ça on a
énormément de choses à faire vous voyez
j'ai pris l'exemple de monter en voiture
électrique au sommet du Lubéron pour
faire une place aux personnes âgées aux
familles ça me semble essentiel je
prends l'exemple des églises de Charente
il me semble qu'il y a plein d'endroits
au fond où on n'a pas cherché à avoir
une politique qui peut faire que le pays
va être plus désirable parce que quand
je dis ça quand vous regardez vous
regardez ça etc c'est des petites villes
en difficulté heureusement Cognac qui
rapporte énormément en ce moment
évidemment donc ça c'est très bien mais
ces territoires là au fond il pourrait
se développer beaucoup plus or le
tourisme fait partie de leur mise en
désir le sud de la France n'était pas
aimé relisez Victor Hugo quand il disait
le sud de la France c'est ça les hôtels
sont pas propres il y a du vent et
d'ailleurs les premiers touristes
n'allaient pas du tout en Méditerranée
ils allaient sur la façade atlantique
ils allaient dans la mer du Nord les
grandes stations c'était ça le nord de
la Bretagne toute la côte belge et cette
côte là la Méditerranée c'est donc la
mise en désir d'un terr c'est un projet
qui intègre le tourisme dans des
activités locales traditionnelles qui
revalides des savoir-faire qu'on peut
mettre en scène grâce au tourisme mais
qui aussi innove dans des nouveaux
métiers dans effectivement des tas de
nouveaux métiers et dans une autre
nouvelle pensée du territoire puisque je
pense que la France se restructure par
ces métropoles et autour des métropoles
à 2h des métropoles il se passe plein de
choses mais qui vous prenez deux heures
de nos grandes métropoles en gros ça
coule quasiment tout le territoire donc
mais c'est une étoile c'est une araignée
donc c'est cette vision or le tourisme
estimait le lieu la destination adhésive
et ce qu'il rattractif je finirai sur
l'exemple j'ai donné de Nantes non tu
étais pas une ville attractive en plus
avec les destructions de la guerre etc
alors et après je dis le château n'avait
pas été restauré mais enfin c'était une
ville qui avait des problèmes
d'attractivité et qui en a qui a trouvé
un attractivité non mais qui joue dans
l'économie qui joue dans les étudiants
qui veulent venir là qui renforcent les
écoles d'ingénieur parce qu'à un moment
y compris la jeunesse elle veut se
former dans des villes où elles pourront
dire avec fierté j'étais formée là et si
ils sont dans une ville personne connaît
aucun image négative la sujet ça n'a pas
envie de l'incorporer dans son cursus
éducatif aussi il faut pas considérer le
tourisme comme un segment par la
fonction du tourisme c'est la gestion
des Irlandes des territoires et cette
gestion désirante elle s'adresse
évidemment au touristes mais elle
s'adresse à l'habitant qui se trouve
valorisé elle s'adresse aux arrivants et
elle s'adresse à l'économie de la
retraite qui je vous rappelle quand même
et l'économie dans plein de
développement de nos sociétés or le
retraiter s'installe dans les lieux
désirable pour les intégrer dans son
cursus de vie on est là dans un ensemble
de processus ou retenant que le tourisme
c'est la mise en désir des lieux et
qu'après il faut gérer effectivement
pour l'effet mais il faut gérer les
effets etc mais pas un voyant comme un
secteur à part il faut le voir comme un
secteur moteur je pense d'ailleurs c'est
la force de la France vous savez je veux
dire c'est quand même un secteur l'image
mondiale de la France est extrêmement
liée au désir du monde de venir en
France on a si on peut avoir 100
millions de touristes mais je veux dire
combien il y en a qui rêvent de venir
ils peuvent pas ils ont pas les sous ils
ont pas les pare-brise
un pays qui est aussi fortement désiré
logiquement après essayer de vendre des
produits français qui ont avoir avec ça
d'ailleurs pour qu'on est si fort avec
L'Oréal avec tous ces objets de soins du
corps de la beauté des femmes etc ça a
quand même avoir avec l'image des
Gironde de la France
merci Bernard fiest
oui merci vous avez un peu répondu à la
question que je voulais vous poser c'est
sur cette inadéquation vous le dites
entre
l'affluxe tourisme et finalement le
manque d'organisation pour pour un peu
gérer ses flux donc je me pose la
question de savoir si la promotion qu'on
fait pour certains territoires et pas
très bonne en revanche l'organisation
pour accueillir les touristes un peu
moins bien mais en même temps
on s'aperçoit qu'il y a aussi
un désir vous allez employer ce terme de
certaines destinations qui n'est pas
promu et pas organisé par les promoteurs
du tourisme mais au contraire par de la
littérature etc donc on aura finalement
toujours un peu de retard il suffit de
voir par exemple le guide quand on va un
endroit on vous dit surtout tel endroit
n'y allez pas c'est fait pour les
touristes ce qu'il faut voir c'est ce
qui n'est pas fait pour les touristes et
on a de plus en plus cette organisation
donc on sera toujours
en retard par rapport au désir et qui
peuvent d'ailleurs fluctuer puisque si
jamais on organise justement cet accueil
des touristes ça deviendra un lieu
touristique qu'il faudra éviter pour
aller vers quelque chose qu'on qui nous
sera présenté comme plus authentique
donc je
comment et est-ce oui l'analyse de
du primum mauvais sur le désir de telles
régions est-ce que alors vous avez parlé
c'est vrai que le cinéma on voit par
exemple les films de Woody Allen qui se
font chaque fois dans des destinations
on se demande d'ailleurs s'ils sont pas
de la promotion pour pour
financés par ailleurs mais il y a la
littérature il y a des choses qui
attirent comme ça brutalement enfin vers
des sites et ça par définition c'était
pas prévisible avant le succès du livre
non mais bien sûr et puis il y a aussi
le fait de rejet dire de rendre plus
qualitatif certains territoires prenez
la Côte d'Azur a priori on dit c'est pas
la peine de s'en occuper mais c'est là
qu'on a écrit L'Opéra de quat'sous la
Côte d'Azur il y a eu des réfugiés juifs
pendant la guerre il y a eu des lieux
magnifiques est-ce que ces lieux sont
fléchés est-ce qu'on peut visiter la
Côte d'Azur des réfugiés allemands par
exemple des créateurs des romanciers des
poètes à Marseille notamment mais après
sur toute la Côte d'Azur la réponse est
non c'est-à-dire que il y a le fait de
rendre une destination je dirais plus
qualifiante pour que parce que si vous
voulez le problème c'est qu'il faut pas
gérer que les flux il y a des gens qui
ne il y a 7 millions de Français parlent
qui vont dans des festivals l'été il y a
4000 festivals bon je pense qu'il y en a
trop il faut y réfléchir est-ce que les
gros festivals sont logiques alors que
d'un point de vue écologique ils sont
absurdes parce que c'est sûr que si vous
faites des petits festivals de proximité
il y a moins de phénomène de transport
donc effectivement il vaudrait mieux
financer les festivals de taille moyenne
que les très gros par exemple vous voyez
toutes ces réflexions ne les mènent pas
bon est-ce que carré il faut financer
carré est-ce qu'il faut financer Avignon
d'un point de écologique c'est une
catastrophe donc comment on gère ces
questions bon je donne pas mon avis mais
on devrait en débattre la septième
première chose mais après si vous voulez
le problème vous avez raison sur la
quête de l'authenticité c'est toujours
elle est derrière le miroir bon et ça
c'est le jeu normal du dévoilement si
vous voulez bon et on vous présente
chaque fois disant là c'est plus
authentique et puis vous rendez compte
qu'en fait souvent c'est quand même des
objets fabriqués en Chine donc
l'authenticité quasiment une mise en
scène dans le territoire on essaie tous
d'y échapper vous savez c'est une
vieille histoire c'est l'opposition du
voyageur et du touriste le touriste a
toujours été méprisé d'ailleurs si on
vous dit tu travailles comme un touriste
c'est une injure le mot arabe si
voyageur et de au 19e siècle dans tous
les règles la grande littérature etc
l'aristocratie c'était des voyageurs les
touristes étaient de nouveau riches donc
il y a toujours ce conflit le sur
tourisme aujourd'hui c'est le met la
même opposition je veux dire il y a un
rejet du tourisme quand je suis de
mauvaise humeur je dis il y en a qui
aiment pas les immigrés arabes il y en a
qui aiment pas les touristes c'est pas
les mêmes monde politique mais il y a un
peu de ça c'est à dire quand même c'est
l'autre qui arrive et comment je le
refuse bon donc je crois qu'il faut
qu'on soit attentif à ça et après je
pense que faire bien le développement
touristique d'un territoire c'est se
mettre dans l'oeil de l'autre c'est si
vous voulez c'est le fait que celui qui
va piloter la mise en territoire ne soit
pas un authentique vous voyez que
souvent j'ai eu des réunions avec les
gens parlent des gîtes ruraux alors les
gens vous disent ah ouais je sais la
maison de ma famille je connais je suis
de la métier de là tu es de la à côté il
y a un truc écrit par qui fait par un
anglais qui est plein tout le temps le
tien il est vide pourquoi ben parce que
l'anglais dis-moi j'ai choisi ce
territoire et je me suis mis à l'aimer
pour telle et telle raison et donc il
dit pas je suis de là donc je suis le
meilleur il dit moi j'ai choisi je vais
vous expliquer pourquoi c'est beau et du
coup ben lui il a des clients beaucoup
plus que l'autre qui dit je suis
authentique
ça se voit très nettement dans les
pratiques le gros problème touriste
c'est qu'on est dans l'oeil de l'autre
et on est dans la mise en désir d'un
territoire qui ne correspond pas
d'ailleurs forcément à l'image pendant
les habitants c'est ça qui est compliqué
parce que les films de la littérature
dont on maintenant les Chéries regardez
des séries de Netflix etc l'importance
que ça peut avoir c'est sur Marseille
avec Depardieu même si elle était
particulièrement mauvaise à mon avis
d'ailleurs ils l'ont arrêté il n'empêche
que vous voyez cette vision parce qu'ils
nous ont fait hésiter la vie dans
l'hélicoptère en fait toute la série est
bâtie sur des photos d'hélicoptères donc
forcément c'est pas la ville qu'on
connaissait on avait envie d'aller voir
bon donc si vous voulez tout ça c'est
pour dire que c'est des vrais jeux il
faut discuter des images parce que les
habitants n'ont pas forcément envie
d'être vus dans l'œil de l'autre donc
comment on gère cette question tout en
se rappelant que 50% des français ne
sont pas nés dans le département et qui
a que 10% des Français qui meurent dans
la commune de naissance donc le discours
de c'est quoi les habitants excusez-moi
les habitants c'est un flux qui est là à
l'instant c'est comme un cheval au galop
faut pas croire que les habitants il y a
une partie effectivement qui sont des
natifs de natifs il y en a quand même
pas tellement et il faut faire très
attention à ce discours sur les
habitants parce que mais après je suis
d'accord qu'il faut que ces images
soient raccords qu'il faut y travailler
mais prenez des gens de l'extérieur pour
piloter vos politiques touristiques et
ça je crois que si vous voulez c'est
c'est un élément extrêmement important
alors il peut aussi y avoir associé à
des gens du coin évidemment mais les
deux regards sont essentiels quoi ça me
semble important le respect des cultures
locales mais aussi dans leur mise en
scène et leur mise en désir pour quand
même aussi renforcer les phénomènes
économiques
merci
Sylvie Vernier
merci Monsieur Viard j'ai une question
courte quel est selon vous le pays qui
réussit le mieux aujourd'hui
l'organisation de son tourisme le ou les
pays
c'est une question compliquée parce que
si vous voulez ça dépend de quelle place
si on se place en termes économique ce
qui rapporte le plus c'est pas la France
on est le premier en quantité disons on
est d'accord là-dessus on va dire mais
pas en chiffre d'affaires en chiffre
d'affaires le premier c'est les
États-Unis non alors qu'ils ont beaucoup
moins tout risque que nous simplement
c'est business business donc si vous
voulez c'est un rapport complètement
différent donc quel est notre objectif
est-ce que notre objectif c'est de
rendre la France désirable dans la
mondialisation pour qu'on vienne la
visiter mais aussi pour qu'on achète des
produits français parce qu'on peut pas
séparer si vous voulez l'intérêt moi
qu'entre nous par exemple faisait la pub
de la voiture à vivre il y a déjà 25 ans
je trouvais ça génial parce que c'était
dans l'imaginaire de la France la France
est un pays de qualité de vie alors
c'est imaginaire sur la beauté des
Parisiennes mais disons qu'on va la
laisser et puis donc de cuisine etc et
tout et donc tous les éléments qui
viennent de là on a envie de les acheter
que ça soit l'Occitane que ça soit
L'Oréal etc dans le monde entier qui
explose parce qu'en gros on mange la
France on achète la France quand un
Allemagne on achète un mouton de du
Ventoux quelque part on est en vacances
quand on mange un morceau de coton du
Ventoux on a le soleil qui rentre dans
la maison etc donc c'est le tourisme
c'est tous ces processus là si vous
voulez pour ça quel est l'objectif
l'objectif financier on n'est pas bon on
pourrait s'améliorer pourquoi on n'est
pas bon mais parce qu'on observe pas
c'est les touristes vous allez en Italie
il pleut il y a tout de suite quelqu'un
qui vous propose un parapluie c'est
inimaginable je veux dire la souplesse
la vitalité tous les petits métiers
alors c'est l'économie italienne mais du
coup bah s'il pleut vous avez un
parapluie bon en France il pleut vous
êtes mouillé bon prendre cet exemple
tout simple qui a pu vous arriver quand
vous déplacer donc pour ça que je dirais
pas quel pays réussie vous voyez
l'Italie a une histoire du tourisme
urbain c'est-à-dire que les Italiens ont
tout on adore les villes italiennes et
visite ville italienne depuis très
longtemps l'Allemagne est dans une phase
de réunification culturelle donc les
Allemands sont en train de découvrir les
villes allemandes il faut dire qu'ils
ont pas pu y aller depuis la guerre donc
se développe un tourisme intérieur
extrêmement important qui n'existait pas
bon vous voyez c'est pour ça que les
modèles sont absolument pas les mêmes il
y a des zones de surdensité touristique
le long de la mer à certains endroits
quand on rentre en Espagne qui est tout
à fait catastrophique nous on a été très
dynamique quand on a fait les plans
neige et quand on a fait les côtes de
Gaulle qu'on a fait effectivement
notamment
l'aménagement du Languedoc et
l'aménagement ensuite après après
Bordeaux ces trucs ont vieillit on n'a
pas réfléchi ces stations moi j'avais
travaillé à Narbonne et tout ça c'est
plus exactement ce que les gens
cherchent mais pour l'instant on fait
rien or la mer est toujours là mais le
problème là c'est qu'il manque le plus
culturel parce que vous êtes dans des
stations béton au bord de mer alors il y
en a qui sont en train de s'intégrer à
la ville modèle Palavas modèle tout ça
ou avec le tramway au fond ça devient
des quartiers urbains et donc du coup
vous avez un nouvel usage parce que vous
avez des gens de la vie s'il habite et
etc et quand les gens sont en vacances
là ils peuvent aller au théâtre ou au
spectacle ou aller aux riches barrières
sur la place de Montpellier donc là vous
avez une construction d'une intégration
avec la ville il y a d'autres endroits
où c'est pas possible à un moment
j'avais suggéré qu'on vende des stations
à des pays étrangers vous voyez qu'il y
a une station anglaise qui est une
station et que tout soit anglais qu'on
roule à gauche et que du coup vous allez
comme en Angleterre font si vous voulez
c'est l'idée c'est de mettre du capital
culturel sur une construction de béton
pourrait le dire comme ça dans les Alpes
vous avez un autre problème c'est que
vous avez le réchauffement climatique et
l'étalement urbain donc en gros le
réchauffement climatique fait que les
stations basses vont petit à petit être
intégrés dans le périurbain de Grenoble
Annecy Chambéry le gap et celle-là au
fond elles vont devenir du Grand
périurbain acceptable les stations d'en
haut elles vont devenir hors de prix
parce qu'elles auront toujours de la
neige donc elles sont de plus en plus
chers réservées à une élite sociale on
va aller vers trois quatre pour cent de
skieur et puis entre les deux entre les
deux ça sera catastrophique et parce
qu'il y aura pas de périurbain et il y
aura plus de skieur et pour le moment je
vois pas de politique se mette en place
sérieusement et on le sait le
réchauffement climatique on le connaît
donc si vous voulez on pourra pas mettre
des canons à neige jusqu'en bas de la
montagne donc là on le voit bien les
installer avec le problème d'énergie
donc si vous voulez on met là sur chaque
fois des exemples différents mais il
faut vous dire il faut que j'y arriver
chaque territoire il faut le travailler
il faut avoir une vision globale de
l'objectif l'objectif c'est 80 % et
effectivement 100 millions de touristes
80% de Français qui part je vais la
démocratisation et surtout une chose il
faut faire partie des jeunes vous savez
quand on est parti jeune on part toute
sa vie si on est parti jeune on part on
est au chômage on part quand même mais
on va plus on va aller chez des copains
on va aller dans la famille on va pas
dépenser d'argent mais le fait de partir
on va pas l'abandonner ça c'est assez
net les jeunes de nos quartiers ils
partent pas l'été sur les plages il y a
pas d'immigrés et ils sont où les 6
millions d'immigrés ils sont dans les
quartiers ou en Afrique
et quand il y a un jeune des travaux de
tarius sont très intéressants dès qu'il
y a un jeune immigré assis sur une plage
toutes les 10 secondes il y a un jeune
européen qui vient lui dire t'as pas du
H il dans son livre il dit c'est
exactement comme un signal de pharmacie
qui clignote vert ben là c'est pas ça
c'est un jeu d'immigré assez
tranquillement sur la plage pour tout le
monde c'est un dealer donc vous êtes sur
tous ces processus il faut faire partir
les jeunes de banlieue parce que c'est
comme ça qu'on les intégrera la culture
française excusez-moi de vous dire
qu'ils se sent tellement excusés et être
exclu du départ en vacances l'été c'est
être exclu de la vie érotique
excusez-moi de dire comme ça mais les
vacances sont le grand lieu d'initiation
amoureuse avant c'était l'effet de votre
type de village mais c'était le temps de
ma grand-mère donc là ce qui ne partent
pas sont exclus aussi de l'ensemble de
ces pratiques d'initiation et d'amour
donc vous voyez et je veux dire voilà un
objectif important j'ai oublié de citer
c'est le départ des jeunes des quartiers
en vacances et de façon effectivement ce
qu'ils aient l'impression d'être
vraiment des Français qui comme tout le
monde qui partent en vacances vous voyez
tous ces choses ça dépend quel objectif
on donne un outil social un objectif de
chiffre ouvert légitime un objectif de
valoriser nos cultures locales pour
qu'on puisse faire du développement
économique à travers notre culture des
vins qui ont des terroirs etc c'est
aussi un objectif je veux dire regarder
comment le rosé de Provence est devenu
effectivement une marque de niveau
mondial et comment la retractivité de la
Provence en matière touristique regardez
les 24-6 de Bandol tout ça de la Côte
d'Azur ils ont gagné aussi c'est-à-dire
que notamment en agriculture il y a une
chaîne entre sur des produits à fort
image de marque et la tractivité
touristique bon je vous rappelle que
cette année on a exporté plus de rosé
que de vin rouge parce que si vous
voulez les autres comme le bordeaux qui
étaient effectivement très assis sur
leur bourgeoisie etc une grande partie
du directeur du bordel il est en crise
très très grave donc voyez les rosés par
contre il s'est appuyé sur une image
touristique ils ont étudié ce que vous
voulez les touristes ils ont compris les
touristes pour le rosé c'est à dire
presque blanc d'abord ils ont changé les
bouteilles ils sont mis à ramasser la
nuit vous allez être le rosé ça sera ma
darnasse maintenant diminue et 6h du
matin pour qu'il démarre plus lentement
et du coup il est plus clair parce
qu'ils ont observé ils ont observé la
demande et donc ils sont adaptés au
marché je pense ces exemples parce que
moi c'est ça qui m'intéressait le lien
entre mise en tourisme construction d'un
discours développement économique local
comment tout ça fait synergie si vous
voulez et c'est pas le tourisme c'est
pas un mois par an déjà qui viennent
claquer leur pognon et on qui en fait
des steaks dégueulasse ça c'est un
produit terminé
crois que vous avez répondu à l'ensemble
des questions c'était très instructif
pour nous ça nous donne des perspectives
de la prospective c'est ce que nous
recherchons donc merci merci Monsieur
Viard et bonne fin de journée merci à
vous aussi bonne journée au revoir